if you want to be good at anything it's  going to take 10 years like I think a  decade is really the best metric that  I've seen in order to go from competency  to you know true competence like 10 000  hours becomes 10 years for you whatever  it is like when I was a swimmer it took  me from age you know 10 to 20 then with  podcasting it's been from 2012 to 2022.  things take time and you can only rush  things so much so instead of trying to  rush it just understand this is what  you're in for relax into it you know  build over time whether you're trying to  build a business develop a client base  like whatever you're trying to get good  at like it's important to think in  decades